[Music]
what's up guys
michael here with yet another rick and
morty season five quick take the latest
episode
a rick convenient mort finds morty
getting into a passionate
probably illegal relationship with
planet tina hey there's a little boy on
her oh
an environmental super person slash
corporatized advocate for recycling over
the course of the episode planetena's
devotion to mother earth quickly turns
her into an arsonist and murderer
and morty can't stomach the whole
killing 300 people side of his new booze
personality but
does planet tina kind of have a point
now before you freak out let us explain
in this wisecrack quick take on rick and
morty
was planeteena right and before we
continue spoilers ahead
but before we get into it i wanted to
tell you guys about something else we do
here at wisecrack
podcast they're like audio versions of
youtube videos except
much longer with multiple very awesome
hosts and on a variety of topics that we
don't have time to cover in our videos
if you want to hear us dive deeper into
our favorite movies from classics to
recent releases and everything else in
between
check out show me the meaning where
hosts austin ryan and raymond plus the
occasional special guest
uncover all of the deeper meaning hidden
beneath the surface of their cinematic
favorites for a breakdown of everything
going on in the cultural zeitgeist
we have culture [ __ ] hosted by serbi
and myself where we use
current events as an occasion to analyze
what's going on in our culture also we
occasionally give weird personal advice
on things like dating and dealing with
your family
finally if you are a fan of rick and
morty we have the squanch where ryan
haley and i explore
all of the madness and meaning in each
new episode of season 5
alongside a special guest we do
everything from analyze episode
structure to uncover the secret
theological and philosophical themes
hidden behind the clones decoys and
ocean lords so check them out wherever
you listen to podcasts and subscribe to
our wisecast channel on youtube
to watch video versions of all of our
podcasts and now
back to the show from the start the
episode is skeptical of how effective
planetina really is
at the outset she's a rhyme-happy
recycling enthusiast who can also stop
acid rain
your acid rain is an acid pain in the
butt
but we quickly learned that she's
functionally an environmentalist
celebrity working at the behest of this
money hungry crew
hey buddy you want an autograph that's
20 bucks a pop planeteen
early environmental efforts are mostly
defined by fun slogans
there's only one solution for earth's
pollution
[Music]
she's an obvious satire of captain
planet and the environmental messaging
of the time while the 70s and 80s saw
plenty of government regulation to stop
environmental degradation despite
reagan's best efforts
political will to expand these efforts
began to fade in the late 80s and early
90s as federal leadership
waned corporations increasingly
undertook voluntary arguably rather
cynical steps to limit their
environmental damage
this so-called corporate
environmentalism was actually pretty
toothless yielding initiatives that
sounded good but didn't do much in what
one activist dubbed
washing but it was enough to stave off
government regulation deliver good
publicity and
pass much of the responsibility for
fixing the environment onto consumers
for example when the plastics industry
poured money into a marketing effort to
popularize recycling supposedly
fixing the whole landfill problem
without the government taking charge
saving the planet became about personal
responsibility
despite the fact that 70 percent of the
world's pollution is caused by just
100 companies and personal
responsibility is planeteena's whole
vibe
encouraging you to recycle batteries
everyone should discard
use batteries at proper disposal centers
instead of tossing them into a regular
waste bin or save a bunny from a forest
fire he traveled 200 miles just to save
a rabbit from the fire
she's probably not really making
significant change her
solutions to pollution like recycling
make people feel good
but don't functionally stop our planet
from dying a fact she doesn't initially
seem to realize
you're not an idiot you're recycled but
when her activism proves ineffective at
stopping some work happy minors
she hits a breaking point so what's a
fed up environmental superhero to do
that's when planeteena goes rogue
setting fire to a mine full of workers
and burning down a congressman's house
is her violent rage justifiable the
murder part definitely not but
burning down a mine that's a little more
complicated
at least according to swedish academic
and activist andreas malm
he argues that change of the magnitude
needed to keep earth inhabitable can
only be achieved if the environmental
movement changes dramatically
specifically he wants activists to
employ strategic acts of violence
against the private property of
polluting corporations as he explains in
his book
fittingly titled how to blow up a
pipeline now to be crystal clear
mom would not have endorsed planetina's
actions he
doesn't believe in causing physical harm
to people
or sentient amalgams of natural elements
but rather to infrastructure that is
hurting the environment
he argues that major positive societal
change
has pretty much only ever happened via
violence from the haitian revolution to
the suffragette movement the latter of
which involved a lot more breaking of
windows and lighting buildings on fire
than you might remember from history
class
importantly he notes that at least in
the suffragette movement not a single
life was lost only empty buildings were
set ablaze
the suffragettes took great pains to
avoid injuring people
while america loves to wax poetic about
non-violent protest
he says this is a whitewashed historical
mythos while every social movement has
plenty of peaceful protesters they also
have members willing to commit radical
acts of strategic violence
in contrast the mainstream climate
movement has especially in recent years
been
mostly corporate friendly and
well-mannered much like planetina
early on there's only one solution for
earth's pollution
meanwhile destructive oil pipelines
continue to be built
and carbon emissions continue to rise
and honestly i'm sweating balls
year-round
he calls this alleged lack of urgency in
the environmental movement
lanchester's paradox the paradox is this
the coming climate crisis
is so urgent and dire with the capacity
to
literally wipe out human existence yet
protests have been
relatively mild mannered he asks at what
point do we escalate when do we start
physically attacking the things that
consume our planet and destroy them with
our own hands
we see planeteena experiencing
lanchester's paradox when she tries to
politely convince the miners not to tear
up the land
to no avail mom argues that this will
always be the case
and that the movement needs to take a
different approach writing
so here is what the movement of millions
should do for a start
announce and enforce the prohibition of
carbon emissions
damage and destroy new co2 emitting
devices put them out of commission
pick them apart demolish them burn them
blow them up let the capitalists who
keep on investing in the fire know that
their properties will be
trashed he argues that if people do this
end mass
eventually it'll stop being cost
effective for corporations to invest in
dirty energy
emissions will go down planets saved no
more oceans on fire
probably in line with malm though again
via murdering people which he explicitly
says
not to do planet gets violent destroying
the mind and its infrastructure so that
it can't pollute anymore
here she goes from focusing on
individual responsibility for pollution
to radically attacking the capitalist
system that has destroyed the planet but
morty for his part
is horrified rejecting her activism and
saying
if that's the only way i i don't want to
be saved and most people would probably
agree
obviously when it comes to murder but
probably also to the destruction of
private property in the name of
environmentalism
malm for his part counters that our
concept of private property
will cost us the earth he gives examples
of successful violent interventions that
involve property damage
such as the 30 attacks on a gas pipeline
that permanently shut down the pipeline
during the egyptian revolution
similar tactics have found success in
ecuador sweden and india to name just a
few of malm's examples
of course most of us aren't about to go
blow up the pipeline did you hear that
fbi
and the problem of a coming climate
crisis can understandably feel too huge
and too terrifying to even contemplate
so
what are most of us effectively doing
interestingly enough
that question brings us to summer and
rick's b plot in which they party hop
from orgy aztec dying planet to orgy as
a dying planet this subplot shows a very
real way some people react to the
climate crisis with the
sort of nihilism this gay sex with my
dad is terrific
what was i thinking it'll all be over
soon hey
the earth is anyhow so why don't we
snort coke through a plastic straw in my
suv while blasting the ac kind of thing
yeah which on second thoughts that
sounds like a very that sounds like a
very dumb idea don't do that
this could be a commentary on the first
world's response to the coming climate
disaster which has been largely
not to do much of anything while we keep
polluting like our lives depend on it
as summer and ricksy it's easier and
more fun to just go with the flow
eat some alien ass and enjoy the ride
while it lasts
oh is that another
especially when change feels so
difficult and so out of reach
such an approach would understandably
probably make mom weep
hey she's the one that saved the world
now we gotta go to work tomorrow
at the same time most people aren't
looking to blow up a pipeline on their
day off
and we feel like that's probably a good
thing but what do you guys think
is violence the only way to stop our
planet from literally catching on fire
or is there a healthy medium ground
between summer and planetina
let us know what you think in the
comments big thanks to our patrons for
all your support
be sure to check out our rick and morty
podcast the squanch
and blow up that subscribe button like
you're saving a planet despite your
grandpa
and don't forget to ring that bell as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
later
[Music]
you